- Yeah.
(fast-paced pop music)
- This week we threw it
all the way back to the 90s
and played with Tamagotchis.
- I honestly don't know how long I've had
my original Tamagotchi.
I actually was a Tamagotchi hoarder.
- I think I had a Neopet or a Giga Pet,
'cause it was free in a
Happy Meal or something.
- I had just lost a tooth and decided
that night that I was gonna write a letter
to the Tooth Fairy saying
that instead of a quarter,
I think it'd be really cool if she
brought me a Tamagotchi.
- Me and my brother got
them because my mom told us
that we had to keep our Tamagotchis alive
in order to get a dog.
We both killed our Tamagotchis
but we still ended up getting a dog,
so I don't know how that
lesson really worked out.
- This little guy just
showed up on my desk,
and without any instructions.
- I'm so excited to rip this open
and start taking care of it.
I really hope I don't kill it.
- The new version is super duper small,
so I'm excited to see how it's gonna be.
Oh my gosh!
It is so little.
I'm gonna pull this tab right now,
which is like the best feeling ever,
and bring him to life.
(beeping)
Ah!
- Juggling this and work
is a little tough.
I have to find a babysitter
when I'm going to
a really important meeting,
because I don't want it to
go off when I'm on a call.
Auntie Liz is taking
care of my Tamagotchi.
- I think I'm feeding him.
- Apparently, my Tamagotchi was beeping
and I had my headphones on at work,
so Tanner yelled at me.
- Yeah.
It was crying and she was ignoring it.
She's a bad Tamagotchi mom.
- Tanner, are you my temp
dad for the Tamagotchi?
- Me and Gotchi, is what I
call my Tamagotchi for short,
had truly one of the best
weekends of our lives.
We went out in the East Village.
We walked the Brooklyn Bridge.
We went to the Giants game.
We shared the most
beautiful New York weekend.
- I feel like I've had
supernatural experiences
with my Tamagotchis,
and this one wasn't an exception.
I'm honestly kind of tired
of taking care of him
'cause there's nothing that
exciting that's happening.
(beeping)
Oh my God!
He totally heard me!
Did you see that?
This Tamagotchi is just like,
he listens.
He's in there. (laughs)
(beeping)
You see?
It's like, it knows.
Every time I call him boring.
- Every single time a poop came up,
I just laughed.
'Cause there's nothing
more funny than poop.
Something happened.
He's got like four poops.
I'm gonna clean up his poops right now.
(beeping)
Oh, he's so much happier.
- Randomly would mess--
Would start pinging me if I was
sitting there not doing anything,
and be like, clean my poop, bitch.
- It did not go as I expected.
I lost my Tamagotchi.
I'm super nervous because
I looked at home, I looked in my desk,
but I can't find it anywhere.
But I did my best.
But, I did find it, right?
It's just dead.
(descending toning)
I just--
Some people aren't meant
to parent things in life,
and I realize that.
- The only fight me and
Gotchi got in this week
was when he woke me up at
7am just beggin' for food.
Morning.
My Tamagotchi won't stop beeping.
It's so annoying.
- Everyone wants to pick it
up and play with the buttons
and feed it and kind of relive
that joy they had when they were a kid.
- You have a Tamagotchi!
- Yeah!
It definitely brought back memories
that I hadn't really thought about
since I moved here.
- One guy actually next
to me on the subway,
who heard the beep go off,
and then turned to me and was like,
whoa, that sound just brought me back
straight to the 90s.
- Even though the experience
wasn't as exciting
as I expected,
I was happy to play like I
used to when I was a kid.
These used to mean so much to me
because they were kind
of my friends on the go,
so it's just cool to think about that.
- Bein' a Gotchi daddy was fun.
Clearly, I'm not cut out to be a parent.
- It made me miss being a
kid and just having fun,
hanging out, and laughing about
cleaning up my Tamagotchi's
poop really brought me
back to my roots, you know?
(laughs) Put it on my
tombstone that I love
to clean up Tamagotchi poop.
It was so fun.
(fast-paced pop music)
(whirring and creaking)